what do you think your purpose is great
question i am asking myself that all the
time i'll bring up that word that that
uh just used a minute ago that brother
christian told me communicate i mean i i
could unpack that word many different
ways for hours
i don't know what my larger purpose is i
just know that
it's to be happy every day i'm grateful
to have the gift of life i'm very
grateful to have the gift of my life and
our purpose i am absolutely convinced is
to find out who we are
and so i think that's our purpose is to
realize that we're much more than what
we're seeing
and i think that's our ultimate purpose
because when we discover that we're free
when we discover it i don't mean as a
concept or intellectually i mean when we
experience it for ourselves
then we are free and then we find
permanent happiness the material pursuit
of success and happiness in and of
itself is limited
and ultimately i've seen people whether
they've conquered it or are trying to
conquer it
have ultimately turned to spirituality
in in every sense so not only from my
own experience have i had amazing
spiritual experiences but from having
observed human experience
uh material things are a need a
necessity and are useful and important
but they are not the goal and so
we you know i don't idolize or demonize
materialism
um
because i live in the world i make money
i'm an entrepreneur i have a home i have
a car
i value all of those things but i don't
value those things to give me a sense of
happiness joy fulfilment or purpose but
i do value them as they are as tools and
energy what you're asking is what's the
point of life yeah
such a question comes because in some
way it's become burdensome
if you were ecstatic you would ask that
question
you asked that question because
somewhere your feet are dragging
because you don't have the throttle
under your right foot anymore
good one really good one i don't know if
i know what the point is yet but
i kind of feel that all of it is the
point
no matter where you're at what you're
doing that's the whole point i remember
byron katie saying what if your purpose
was right here right now in this moment
if you'd asked me a few years back what
i thought the point of this existence
was i would say
to experience duality but what i
realized in
the
dualistic nature of life the good and
the bad the more bad i felt the more i
realized without without getting a good
the more easy i was able to access joy
and happiness in simple moments okay all
this stuff's out here i sense it i see
it i witness it more and more versus
getting drawn in and really i'm just
pulling it in here i'm staying in here
i'm showing up here this is how i can
serve the most i know my truth i need
less and less from the outside and
here's where i create from and this is
where our best stuff comes forward
every time i push the goal post a little
further or every time i break a glass
ceiling for myself i'm just like that
gives me the largest sense of purpose i
did everything this poor kid i was
rubbing spoons on them i had mormons
come over to do a prayer i had like
anything i could possibly read like
injecting them with just
detox and
you name it
but
by the grace of god
he uh he got better he got better and he
got better and he got better and i was
like all right maybe this is another one
of my missions maybe this is the only
reason i became famous is to actually
help mothers and dads and families
who might have a chance of their kid
getting a little bit better
my purpose
well i know that this may not be the
answer but i'm
i'm a storyteller
that's that's what i always
when i first went to film school before
i ever started acting i just said i
remember saying i just want to be the
storytelling business
if i could make a living telling stories
how fun would that be how could that be
and to this day 20 30 years later i
still consider myself i'm in the
storytelling business um
and if i can tell a story
in a way which i've been told i did so
in the book that you can go oh that's
more than just a good story yes that was
entertaining absolutely
but also it enlightened me in this way
it educated me in this way it made me
think about myself it gave me more
questions and or confidence or made me
say i'm gonna reapproach this thing i'm
four stories being for for entertainment
solely and there's great value in that
but i'd also i also like stories that i
can go
why can't i take something that into my
own life and i'm going to go out and
give that a boot i'm going to try that
out and see what that music is it comes
back to me if a more true music comes
back to me if i apply that and take that
and the way that i see the world and the
way that i wake up in the morning the
way that i look my wife in the eye first
thing in the morning the way i embrace
my kids first thing what then what do i
get back
and
i usually find that you know and i don't
follow it all the time but i'm still you
know
working on it as i said i don't think
i'm ever landing i don't think we ever
have a tada moment
um and i think that's the point
um
but you know you you
when you get that reciprocity back to
you
and you are catching green lights you
all feel like you are on your frequency
you are dancing through the world you're
taking the tough stuff and you're
dancing by it and through it and
handling you're taking the good stuff
with grace gracing confidence and
compounding assets to the future when
that's happening
and you're do actually doing more it's a
very
selfish
thing to experience because it feels
good people talk about charities
you know
there's a selfish endeavor to give
i selfishly feel great when a child at
our foundation
eyes light up and goes you're the one
you're the first person that's ever done
something for me that's not asking for
something back and you don't even know
me why thank you
that's me feeling good selfishly feels
good i have written uh
well played because that's what i wanted
my tombstone just well played
you know it was like
life gave you some stuff you did some
[ __ ] you cleaned it all up it's just
well played because because really it's
just a big
game so if we look at every experience
as a game and here we are in this moment
on the board what are we going to do
what move are we going to make that's it
right it's being present and going and
what if that's it what if everything is
every moment of the game
when in some way you don't live your
life joyfully enough intensely enough
you wonder
what is the point of my existence
because human intelligence is made this
way if it doesn't figure out
if it doesn't figure out all aspects of
life it will feel incomplete
if you had the brains of an earthworm or
a grasshopper you would be fine eating
sleeping reproducing and dying one day
but once you come with this level of
intelligence and awareness
you have to look deeper into your life
because your life is not fixed like
their life
nature has drawn two lines for all of
them they just have to live within that
and go for you there are no lines
this freedom is what everybody's
suffering
you know everyone does have a unique
purpose and calling and this book begins
with my favorite verse from the
bhagavad-gita which says it's better to
follow your own path imperfectly
than to follow another's perfectly
and to me that is the root of all of our
growth or issues because i'm just trying
to follow my path the best i can i
genuinely feel i'm doing what i was
meant to be doing and what i was born to
do and
and i feel very aligned in that sense
and it's taken me a long time to get
here and i'm still trying to constantly
align every day it's not like it's done
and it's achieved and and i just want
everyone to
align with their greatest calling
because we need everyone in this world
and to live that way we don't just need
a few people we need everyone to feel
aligned with their purpose and their
their calling so thank you for allowing
me to share this with your community and
and uh your audience thank you so much
yeah what if this is it
it's like i'm i feel complete you know
it's like yeah this is great if nothing
else happened other than this moment i
feel good
i feel clear